When I give £10 in charity and it is
consumed, the rewards come to an end.
However, if I give to a wak, then you've
put your money into something permanent.
It's a endowment that continues to give
on your behalf until the day you meet
Allah subhana wa tala. Subhan Allah.
That is amazing. Here at IM Legacy,
brothers and sisters, we want you to
build a legacy with your saddaka. Where
would your donation be going? events,
global events inspiring the iman of
millions around the world. Education,
free Quran lessons, free lectures, free
reminders. Number three, media content
for kids, educational shows, spiritual
Islamic shows online, brothers and
sisters. Go to the link inshallah and
donate in this blessed 10 days
inshallah. May Allah bless you guys.
Asalam alalaykum
brothers and sisters and dear friends.
So, we've got some up updates inshallah
regarding what's going on in Israel.
Iran has uh done its second night uh of
the second wave of attacks once again
overwhelming the Iron Dome and the
defense system the air defense system in
Israel and then hitting them with
ballistic missiles. Here are footages
and not only that we have some updates
regarding Muhammad bin Salman who has um
actually said he defends Iran which is
very shocking to me. Uh we're going to
read that article and why he said that.
It's it's quite surprising he stands
with Israel. We're going to find out in
here's a footage inshallah. One of the
footage show a university uh campus uh
that's actually getting hit. So what you
see in the screen right now is a footage
from a CCTV camera and this is um when a
ballistic missile hits Tel Aviv
obviously this occupied lands or
Palestine. Um and as you can see um
subhan Allah it hits quite a bit of a
distance but this is next near a I think
a medical university or something like
that along those lines. Uh so you can
see and the smoke the fire as you
another explosion happens. Subhan Allah.
Uh so as you can see and uh bear in mind
uh that the Mossad building the
headquarters and the miniature instru
infrastructure and miniature zones which
could have been anywhere else for some
odd reason they have them in a highly
densed populated uh places and you can
see clearly the narrative of uh human
shields where it actually stems from
that's why they say every accusation is
a confession that these liars these
absolute dirt bags are absolutely liars.
That's what they are. And again, I just
want to say we condemn the killing of
any innocent people from either side
from Iran or uh Israel. Even though they
may be Zionists, but they are not our
teachers. We do not want any innocent
people to die. So the next footage here
is as you can see um you know the the
Iron Dome, the air defense system
intercepting some of these missiles. But
you can see a lot of them are getting
through. A lot of them are getting
through. And this shows to be honest the
weakness of Israel's air defense system
when it comes to the Iron Dome. Um you
would think, oh no, it's not. And it
gives once again it makes you it makes
very clear that uh without America's
funding and other nations and having
their air defense system Jordanian
Jordanians defending them you know um um
intercepting the missiles that's come
from Iran and many other places. I think
um Israel you know will not um you know
will be in heavy bombardment. Another uh
footage that we have here as you can see
brothers and sisters in front of me um
is the the footage of the destruction
that's happened and some of you guys
might look at this and think this is
Gaza this is Palestine and no this is
inside Israel this is occup this is
actually Palestine but it's stolen land
as you guys can see and you know this is
this is you know the concept you cannot
you cannot bully massacre innocent
people and think you're going to get
away with it yes okay just as you say
Israel has a right to defend itself then
the same thing can be said about Iran
has a right to defend itself, you know,
why is there double standards? Why is it
seen as, oh, this is preemptive, you
know, and then you've got another
footage here. Uh, and we also have uh,
look, these rockets um, actually
hitting, subhan Allah, um, Tel Aviv look
direct. Oh my gosh, like that's, you
know, you can see, you can see clearly.
Subhan Allah. This third one, I don't
know. It looks AI, but I'm not sure. It
looks a bit like AI or, you know, but
anyways, I don't know. So, you can see
the missiles are hitting all across Tel
Aviv. Yes. I mean, just imagine you're
walking in London and you just see these
ballistic missiles flying all over the
place. It is quite scary. Uh but you
know, um this what happens when you you
know, it's it's like an eye for an eye,
you know, you attack a sovereign nation
um without without being provoked, you
know, and you you know, you you want to
be um a a victim bizarrely. Um and not
only that, there were actual footages of
um Zionists Zionist settlers actually uh
leaving or trying to attempt to leave
Israel, the holy lands that they so
believe in leaving. And there's another
one. Look that just hit there as you can
see. Subhan Allah. And yeah, this is the
airport. This is the Benurian airport.
Uh as you can see the Zionist um fleeing
fleeing their homeland, their holy land
as you can see. Subhan Allah. And it's
it's it's it's unbelievable. It's
unbelievable. And the last footage that
we have here, as you can see, um those
um ballistic missiles has been
intercepted, but one of them goes
straight through and hits um a building
or some in Talib. And you can see the
iron dome obviously in the pro bit there
going somewhere. He hasn't done his job,
mate. Uh yeah, and now let's go to
Muhammad bin Salman. Okay, but so it
says NBS says Islamic world backs Iran
in call with PZ Peshia. Okay. So, Saudi
Crown uh Prince Muhammad bin Salman has
condemned Israel's attack on Iran and
affirmed this country his country's
support for Thran. That's that's that's
a massive thing. Saudi crown Saudi Crown
Prince Muhammad bin Salman strongly
condemned Israel's attacks on Iran and
exposed expressed condolences for the
Iranians life lost. If a phone call in a
phone call with Iranian President Mossad
Mossad Masoud Padish Khan bin Salman
declared Saudi Arabia stands with its
brothers in Iran and will spare no
effort to support them, emphasizing that
the entire Islamic world is united in
backing Iran. Iran I mean I'm a bit I
don't know what to make of that. To me
it's just like talk but I don't know
what to make of that. The crown prince
stressed that Riyad was using all
diplomatic channels to pressure for an
anti-Israeli aggression, warning that
Israel's actions were aimed at
escalating tensions and creating a
pretext for US intervention. A a wise
and measured response from the Islamic
Republic of Iran, he said, will prevent
them from seizing that opportunity.
True. Uh, President Pesh Peshkan in turn
accused Israel of sabotaging every
effort Iran has made towards regional
peace and stability. He thanked Salman
for Saudi Arabia's cooperation in
serving pilgrims and called for greater
unity among Islamic nations to counter
what he described as Israeli regimes um
crimes especially in Gaza. Pedeskan
added that Saudi Arabia gave its
regional and religious influence could
play a pivotal role in fostering
solidarity across the Muslim world to
uphold the rights of the Muslims in the
region. Uh also Peshkan vows devastating
response to Israel's aggression. So
they're warning them. Uh Peshkan vowed
on Friday that the Islamic Republic of
Iran would deliver a powerful powerful
and legitimate response to Israel's act
of aggression on Iran, warning that the
enemy would deeply regret its actions.
Israel launched a major attack on Iran
in the early hours of Friday, targeting
residential buildings, nucle nuclear
facilities, and military infrastructure
across Iran. In a televised address to
the nation, Pesh Khan clarified that
Iran would not remain silent in the face
of Israel's criminal and international
international unlawful attack. The
Iranian nation and the country's
officials will not remain silent in the
face of this crime and the legitimate
and powerful response from its from the
Islamic Republic of Iran will make the
enemy regret its foolish actions, he
declared. And lastly, the Iranians
president condemned the Israeli
aggression as a blatant violation of
international norms, describing it as
yet another example of Zionist uh
regime's criminal behavior and the
attacks that Israel made on a specific
apartment building to take out uh
generals and command commanders. They
killed 60 people which 20 of them are
children and they are known to
innocently they are known to attack and
killed innocent men, women and children.
So this is the reason why when Pers
Morgan says what's the proportional
response or you know how many uh people
have you killed to them it's killing 60
innocent people to take one command out
is worth it because the human life of
the Muslims and uh the other is not as
valuable as their Israeli lives. Brother
and sisters we will keep you updated
inshallah as time goes by. Do not forget
to check my Zan J's channel with amazing
upto-ate news inshallah sisters. Um and
yes keep up to date very closely
inshallah and we are monitoring this.